anybody who blows the whistle
immediately raises a question is it the
individual is it the organization my
view any organization which has a
whistleblower ought to start from the
supposition that they are right there is
an issue to address until prove to the
contrary
and when I say proved I do mean proved
if I had to hazard an opinion in most
cases there is an element of truth about
any whistleblowing allegation it may not
be absolutely true but it may indicate
something that is a problem perhaps not
exactly the problem indicated and that
in itself paradoxically is valuable to
an organization I mean what we know from
history is that in quite a lot of cases
people blew the whistle nobody paid any
attention it would have been a lot
better if the whistle blow have been
listened to
that doesn't mean say all whistleblowers
are right but this is a serious issue
actually scandals coming to the open may
be a very healthy sign because in my
experience twenty thirty years ago a lot
happened that was never reported never
discussed and it certainly wasn't
ethical these kinds of practices today
are much more likely to come out in the
open so in that respect therefore I'm
rather an optimist in terms of the
general trend will they always be
ethical issues I think the will the
borderline in terms of what is ethical
and not ethical shifts all the time and
we're not all the same as people we are
very different across countries across
cities across continents it's
unreasonable to believe that everybody
will behave in the same way I believe
that actually there are more checks and
balances now in terms of ethical
behavior than the were before if you go
back 30 40 50 years ago the environment
why was one in which people kept very
quiet about most things you didn't
discuss them people things were carved
up quietly behind the scenes in a way
that today would be regarded as
completely unacceptable and quite
rightly so
in that respect therefore is there an
ultimate answer you know will we all
behave ethically no the question is are
the mechanisms there to bring them into
the open and to cope with them and not
to eliminate them because we will never
do that but to minimize their harmful
effects